[Music]
hi my name is Rick Melendez and I live
in the beautiful town of Parker Colorado
I am married to a wonderful woman Myrna
and we have two wonderful educated and
beautiful daughters Brittany and Brianna
both of them are recent college
graduates the amazing universities here
in Colorado
I'm also a current federal government
employee working as a program and
project manager murder and I also own a
small business doing consulting in the
project management and federal
procurement communities originally from
Honduras Central America my family moved
to the bustling City of New Orleans in
the U.S when I was around 12 years old
in 2009 I retired from the service as a
senior master sergeant and promptly
found employment with the U.S federal
government since then I've worked for
several federal agencies overseeing
complex I.T systems designed to provide
health human and Social Services a few
years ago I started feeling a bit
stagnant in my career so I started
looking at the latest trends in project
management while researching for a
suitable training I came across simply
learn after reviewing several courses I
was initially attracted to the project
management Institute agile certified
professional or PMI ACP course that's
simply learn offer needless to say every
review that I read had glowing numbers
from the well-laid curriculum to the
professionally made videos specifically
focused on each course topic this was
one of the best online courses I've ever
taken the course curriculum and
resources it provided as well as the
personal motivation and discipline to
prepare myself for the certification
allowed me to be certified as a PMI ACP
which is one of my most cherished
certifications
to be successful in life I truly do
believe that one needs to take the time
and put the effort to continue to expand
your knowledge Horizon so make an effort
and continue to invest in yourself I
know I have and it continues to pay off
tremendously
[Music]